extrait du dvd vendus avec le livre de
dominique rocheteau publié au cherche
midi
on m'appelait l'ange vert parce que j'ai
voulu faire ressortir de ces fois la
différence de football par rapport à
maintenant on va déjà au niveau du jeu
il ya l'engagement physique et le qui
n'est pas le même mais il ya chez pas à
mon époque
bon je préfère anciens combattants mais
il y avait un autre respect au niveau 2
du des joueurs de 17 $ mythe aussi parce
que mal en ce moment serait créée il ya
pas mal de problèmes alors vous raconter
dominique rocheteau dans ce livre votre
incroyable en france
dire qu'au lycée dès que vous avez votre
licence minimes
votre objectif c'est de marquer des but
et vous marquez début nous embarquer 139
36 matches c'est un marqueur de buts 1
c'est votre truc quoi je pense que ça en
moi et c'est ça ouais tu n'as pour
réussir il vaut mieux être obsédé mais
en tous les cas et alors à saison vous
jouez en cadets à la rochelle vous être
repéré vous êtes repéré par le fameux
garraud pierre garonnaire donc et le
terrain de scouts de saint-etienne et
qui vous emmène là bas quoi mouais mais
ce n'est pas évident enfin moi je en
fait à l'époque 15 ans je n'ai pas vu
beaucoup de matchs de foot juste un bon
petit village
et je rêvais pas vraiment d'être un
footballeur professionnel je mets le
message c'était ma passion mais bon an
mal an la belgique aussitôt des passeurs
de stars de rock mais pas de foudre
alors essayé puis impressionné par les
beatles et les stones à l'époque par les
joueurs ouais ouais ouais on voit que
l'amérique est un peu quand même hein
voilà et quand vous arrivez à
saint-etienne en fait vous vous rendez
compte que vous avez pas la condition
physique et vie est obligée de choisir
entre le bac et le foot et vous
choisissez le foot
ouais ouais puis pendant trois ans pas
mal de galères de blessure vont-ils donc
qu'il arrive cette période là où avec
eux là où j'avais tout de suite en
équipe de france est un kovacs ouais
alors lis cette fameuse épopée des verts
le gène bathenay janvion revelli
sarramagna ses indications que j'ai fait
une équipe en france qu'il fasse de
telles tel succès il n'y avait même pas
eu d' équipe à l'exception de race du
grand reims des 58 salopards la fontaine
comparer sur leoni mais sinon des
équipes de club saint-etienne a été la
première puis s'était quand même même
s'il parle du passé comme ça ça a été la
première équipe de dimension européenne
se maintient
ça a été très fort pascal épique aller à
l'époque de reims avait que 3 4 équipes
enfin 4,5 j'ai exagéré alors que à
l'époque de dominique s'était déjà garni
elle bayern est belle à jacques un bon
et c'est vrai que c'était saint-ayoul
deux phénomènes presque en même temps il
ya eu deux phénomènes qui ont été là
l'arrivée de saintes et l'éclosion de
cette équipe de saint-etienne une équipe
de jeunes où il n'y a pas de stars et
puis en même temps c'est un peu la
conséquence l'équipe de france de michel
hidalgo et de michel platini dont
faisait partie dominique est c'est vrai
que ça relancer le football français au
milieu des années 70 il y a une
formidable relance du football français
grâce à une équipe de club saint-etienne
et à l'équipe nationale de d'hidalgo et
après tout a découlé de la coi voilà
c'est l'histoire du foot par eugène
saccomano voilà alors vous étiez très
différent des autres vins
d'abord j'étais branché rock'n'roll
jefferson airplane hot tuna eagles neil
young chicago america donc quand même un
un jour des deux parties sur la côte
californienne pour écouter du rock and
roll donc ça c'est une chose que m
concert et l'autre chose aussi qui vous
différencier des autres c'était la
politique sert que vous aviez lu marx
proudhon bakounine
j'ai quand même rare chez les valeurs
j'imagine l'on suit quelques influences
il ya très peu d influence familiale
ouais il votre père oui le père était
communiste
oui mais vous c'est pire bakounine c'est
carrément anarchiste ouais mais c'est
vrai nom mais dans le football c'est
vrai que actuellement on a été basée à
moi j'ai été très étonné que domenech
soit choisie comme coach entraîneur de
l'équipe de france parce que c'est un
type qui qui connaît qui va au cinéma
qui fait du théâtre qui lit des livres
c'est d'empêcher trôner en plus pour les
dirigeants de la fédération
il ya aussi un footballeur actuellement
qui s'appelle dhorasoo c'est un peu
pareil
il aime le cinoche une à venir j'ai été
un stage vous étiez dans les pyrénées
c'était quelqu'un saison pour vivre
enfin font romeu et c'était très
frappant parce que il y avait rocheteau
et tigana qui en effet discuter ou de
politique ou de romans etc mais c'était
vraiment les deux seuls qui m'a frappé
les autres c'est qu'ils jouent au baby
foot c'est après que je me suis résolu à
défendre à la hausse que très bizarre
c'est que votre lecture de marx de
proudhon de bakounine nous a pas empêché
de devenir ami avec la veuve de louis
ferdinand céline du set
oui par le biais de ma femme marie
s'était d'ailleurs on avait engueulé
on l'avait emmené voir des princes on a
amené lucette almanzor parc des princes
voir match de football avec toute la
bande de de céline c'est à dire gibeau
un concept dit l'acteur jean-françois
stévenin
ouais mais bon c'est un moment
intéressant pour moi je comprends qu
après on peut enfin je comprends on peut
apprécier le talent mais les filles et à
l'école je me souviens qu'à l'école on
avait étudié céline et beaucoup d élèves
dans la classe pas que des juifs
d'ailleurs avait c'est avait dit on veut
pas étudié céline voilà c'est que c'est
comme si on étudiait pour moi ont un jeu
c'est pas quelqu'un de pédophile qui a
beaucoup de talent et écrit un très beau
livre ou plusieurs très beaux livres ou
un grand enfin je sais pas je ne
comprends pas c'est ça vous choque
la libération la négation de gênes ou de
l'un d'eux dominique pour céline
sallette shox m
non mais ça me gêne mais personnellement
je sais le problème c'est pire que ça
c'est que à la fois il écrit au moins un
livre je pense qu'ensuite il écrit
toujours le même lit que c'est toujours
le même procédé que ça devient mais il a
au moins écrit un livre dont
incontestablement est un monument de la
littérature française d'une révolution
dans l'histoire littérature ses voyages
et à la fois c'est anr est à la fois
c'est un être absolument abjecte s'avère
bien pire encore que ce que si on
connaît sa vie tient qu'à un capable
d'amour ne nous ne ressentons que de la
haine du rejet de l'eau de la méchanceté
que l'état et donc c'est tout le
problème
c'est tout le problème d'eau à mort
devant son immense talent et tu sais
très bien qu'il était il était quand
même fou quelque part et d'ailleurs
c'est celle où toute façon toujours
reconnu mais sa folie lui a permis
d'écrire des pages écran hummer ya
personne dans ce siècle qu'à crier aussi
fort que lui et aidants et dans toutes
les directions
c'est ça dans toutes les ruelles doit
faire abstraction de l'oeuvre de lola ce
qui tue accès à l'école oui cela me
choque
est-ce qu'on choisit lui donc vient
après ça peut donner des idées à
d'autres ça peut être à peu près normal
acceptées jusqu'au voilà c'est pas
dénoncés en tous les cas à l'école c'est
pas dénoncer quand on les tue 10 10
avant c'était un sacré [ __ ] mais il a
écrit c'est parce qu'ils disent donc
j'ai encore plus j'apprends qu'il est à
l'école qui enfin qu'il est sur les
manuels et en terminale on promet et
vous dominique un des deux ou trois plus
grands écrivains du avec proust
enfin je pense si on aime ou on aime pas
bon et moi je comprends parfaitement les
gens qui n'aiment pas à cause du du
personnage mais je m'évertue à dire que
le personnage ne compte pas tellement
étant donné qu'il était il est un peu
cinglé avait été créée superbement bien
s'arrêter révolution d'écriture est ce
qu'on l'aurait étudiée aliments
cependant avec pas la même chose pas du
tout pourquoi il ya des travaux qui sont
nuls
céline c'est pas simplement un outil
pour 10 mai antisémite céline c'est un
type qui à 44 va voir les allemands pour
leur dire qu'ils ne tuent pas assez de
juifs
c'est ça et qu'il l'écrit gérant on
n'imagine pas
ensuite il ya eu la reconversion
dominique.papais ya maintenant un blanc
d'un vous avez dit c'est la ménopause du
joueur voit quand il s'adonne donc dans
votre bouquin alors d'abord vous avez
voulu être agent en essayant d'être
plutôt effectivement à un grand frère
qu'un patron ouais c'est ce que j'ai
essayé de faire
vous êtes finalement je n'avais pas
l'âme d'un patron quoi je n'étais pas
fait pour faire ça j'ai mal à mon homme
d'affaires couasnon en panne homme
d'affaires puis pour donc moi que je
suis orienté vers les derniers mois mais
j'aime bien avec les enfants
vous avez fait du cinéma aussi avec
pialat faisait tourner dans le gard sud
ouais ouais l'appareil a dit tu seras le
prochain lino ventura ouais vous a
vraiment dit ça mais 10,1 au fond vous
êtes toujours resté l'ange vert non je
pense pas donc je pense pas non non non
des monts verts peut-être des monts
verts
m
mais les
les jurés